[Music]
which big bang theory characters went
out smiling
and which ones had truly terrible
finales
here are the endings of every major big
bang theory character
ranked from worst to best because not
all character endings are created equal
by season 7 lovesick and lonely raj
played by kunal nair has completely
given up
on meeting women by traditional methods
in favor of online dating
until enter emily sweeney played by
laura spencer
after emily sends a message to raj the
two begin a slowly developing
relationship
the news that raj has a steady
girlfriend is so huge in fact
that the big bang theory treats it as a
bigger deal than when leonard and penny
announced their engagement
sadly in season 9 raj messes up a good
thing dumping emily to pursue new
possibilities in the name of
claire played by alessandra torresani
of course as you might have already
guessed claire rejects poor raj
emily shows up just enough to remind
viewers she's moved on with a new
boyfriend
and that intimacy problems with raj help
doom their relationship from the
beginning
all this makes emily's finale more of a
bust than a bang
when the show started the four male
characters on the big bang theory
all had very different approaches when
it came to hooking up with members of
the opposite sex
hi hi hi
hi howard played by simon hellberg
wanted cheap tawdry physical pleasures
leonard hofstetter played by johnny
galecki
only wanted to be with kaylee cuoco who
played penny
of course sheldon played by jim parsons
found the whole notion of romance a
strange distraction from his scientific
work
would you be open to rotating the couch
clockwise 30 degrees
meanwhile raj harbored an innocent
dreamy
fairy tale idea of romance ironically
he was the one who struggled the most
with his love life
over time raj maintained a few
relationships
lucy played by kate micucci emily
played by katie leclaire and of course
claire
and the other emily still when a
character's whole goal
is to seek out love it's disappointing
they don't get to have it when their
show ends
in the final episode raj even pays sarah
michelle geller of buffy the vampire
slayer
to attend sheldon and amy's nobel prize
ceremony as his date
is that buffy the vampire slayer
which is just plain sad
melissa rouch first popped up as
bernadette on the big bang theory
early in season three when she was set
up with howard
the two hit it off and a few episodes
later
roush permanently joined the cast over
the course of the show
bernadette progresses in both her work
life and personal life
starting out as a cheesecake factory
server alongside penny to pay for her
doctorate
bernadette eventually becomes a
well-paid and highly regarded researcher
at a pharmaceutical company
bernadette marries howard at the end of
season five
and five years later they welcome their
first daughter
halle before long baby neil is born and
that makes four in the household
bernadette's story is maintained for the
final season of the big bang theory
where she's a harried working mother of
two dealing with day-to-day stressors
without too much really happening with
the character
for most of his run on the big bang
theory stuart bloom
played by kevin sussman remained a
steady
unchanging character stewart serves as a
worst-case scenario comparison for the
main characters
if they consider themselves nerds who
have a hard time attracting women and
interacting with mainstream society
stuart shows them that their situation
could be a lot worse look at me i'm
37 i sleep in the back of a comic book
store and i had the bone density of an
80 year old man
he's the owner of the big bang boy's
favorite comic book store
a guy who freely discusses his fears and
anxieties about the store closing
and leaving him in economic ruin as well
as his inability to
maintain any sort of romantic
relationship with the opposite sex
in other words he's the geek shunned by
the other geeks
and the major characters keep him at
arm's length
as if his bad luck is contagious by the
big bang theories finale however
stewart has finally found love admitting
his feelings for comic store employee
denise
played by lauren lapkus who returns the
sentiment
you are so hot but neither are
considered close enough to the gang to
attend the nobel prize ceremony in
sweden
instead they stay in california to
babysit howard and bernadette's kids
which in classic stuart fashion is a
disaster
penny seems happy at the conclusion of
the big bang theory
but is she really comparing the penny at
the end of the show to the one at the
beginning
reveals a changed woman and not
necessarily for the better
i'm also writing a screenplay it's about
this sensitive girl who comes to la from
lincoln nebraska to be an actress and
winds up a waitress
at the cheesecake factory when she moves
across the hall from sheldon and leonard
she's bubbly friendly and fueled by her
dream of becoming an actress and
screenwriter
but as the show goes on penny's
character begins to change
dealing with a fussy rude sheldon and a
tumultuous relationship with leonard
turns her into the show's source of
put-downs and eye-rolling
often with a large glass of wine to cope
with what her life has become
apart from roles in a few humiliating
b-movies and commercials
penny never does make it as an actress
she abandons that career for a more
lucrative but less fulfilling one
as a pharmaceutical rap at least her
romantic life settles down
penny marries leonard who worships the
ground she walks on
in the final episode penny tells her
husband that she's pregnant
despite making it clear that she had no
intention of becoming a mother
in the end nothing turned out the way it
was supposed to for penny
only one person on the big bang theory
absolutely hates sheldon
and he isn't afraid to let him know yeah
we're talking about
fellow caltech scientist barry kripke
played by john ross bowie he's the
workplace equivalent of a schoolyard
bully who taunts
cooper kripke yes
you're in my spot in the final season
kripke gets his redemption
and he gets to mock sheldon one last
time
even though sheldon rejects his request
to fund a project
he offers to help sheldon prove that one
of his rivals for the nobel prize
is a fraud later when sheldon is
awaiting the phone call to see if he won
that very big honor
kripke prank calls him pretending to be
the organizers from sweden
and that's how kripke goes out teasing
sheldon
until the very end the big bang theory
scored a major cast and coup
when mayam bialik joined the cast in
season three
like castmate and ex roseanne star
johnny galecki
bialik was a former teen sitcom actor
familiar to millions as the title
character on blossom
additionally bialik studied in a field
similar to that of her character on the
big bang theory
amy farah fowler as it turns out
the performer has a doctorate in
neurobiology
adding some realism to her role as a
neuroscientist
i got my phd in um in neuroscience from
ucla
in her early appearances amy is quiet
and lonely
with no one in her life except for her
lab animals
big bang theory writers however leaned
into the idea of having amy be a match
for the also forever solo
sheldon cooper eventually the
romantically driven amy gets sheldon to
do things he's never considered doing
like kissing and getting married it's no
surprise that such a logical
direct character would wind up getting
exactly what she wants
the ideal husband to match the ideal
career
in the final episode of the series amy
achieves what only a handful of
scientists ever do
she wins a nobel prize to say to all the
young girls out there
who dream about science as a profession
go for it sharing the nod with
you guessed it sheldon before she
winds up with leonard penny brings a few
guys home to meet her friends
zach johnson played with relish by brian
thomas smith
is a classic sitcom jock big athletic
looking but also noticeably stupid
one question how can you be sure it
won't blow up
the laser the moon like a human version
of a dog
zack is dumb but he doesn't care plus
he's friendly to everyone
feeling threatened by this man who
represented every high school bully who
ever
dunked them into a toilet or trash can
the cast of geeks insult him to his face
and talk bad about him behind his back
zach gets the happy ending he deserves
he forms a menu design company
and sells it for millions he also gets
over penny
and marries a woman named marissa played
by
lindsay kraft who is just as dim and
kind
as he is while sheldon cooper endures
the nasty
childish taunts and pranks of barry
kripke
his true enemy is will wheaton the
former
child star who played wesley crusher on
sheldon's beloved star trek the next
generation
so what's up with the hatred well
wheaton failed to show up for an
autograph session sheldon worked hard to
attend
whedon played himself over several
episodes of the big bang theory
usually to gleefully antagonize sheldon
for example in a card game tournament he
explains that he missed that fateful
autograph session to be with his sick
grandmother
and sheldon close to his own grandmom
lets his guard down
in a rare show of empathy leading
wheaton to win
even though wheaton was lying about his
grandmother the whole time
i call my meme on nana and she's going
to be very happy to hear that my small
rock
kills your enchanted bunny in the final
season of the big bang theory
the characters square off once more when
both are gunning to play
children's science show host professor
proton a role that opened up after the
death of the original actor
played by bob newhart wheaton rightfully
gets the gig
devastating sheldon a fitting end for
the well-qualified
rogue leonard hofstadter is a brilliant
scientist with a lot to brag about
he has workplace accomplishments and
makes major scientific achievements
ultimately the prestigious caltech
researcher has
one goal above else he wants to wind up
hitch to penny and live happily ever
after
in the big bang theories pilot leonard
claims he's going to have children with
penny someday
our babies will be smart and beautiful
and after some initial disinterest on
her part
some will they won't day ups and downs
the pair
finally get hitched and officially
settle
however there's one major issue in the
pairing between the energetic actress
and the goofy scientist he wants to
start a family
she doesn't in the finale however penny
excitedly tells leonard
that she's expecting someone's gonna
figure it out when we just tell people
oh it's too early haven't you wrapped my
head around it i have my head is wrapped
that means leonard gets his dream woman
along with his prophecy fulfilled too
it's yet another win for leonard on top
of all
that near the end of the series leonard
reconciles his tense and cold
relationship with his intimidating
mother
psychiatrist and neuroscientist dr
beverly hofstetter
played by christine baranski so
i forgive you way to go leonard
the one character that changes the most
throughout the 12 season run of the big
bang theory
who gets to enjoy one of the most
definitive accomplished and meaningful
endings
is howard wallawitz way back in season
one
howard was the closest thing the show
had to a villain
it's unsettling how he relentlessly hit
on penny
even though she stated several times
that she found both the man
and his method unattractive and
repulsive
you may be familiar with some of my work
it's
currently orbiting jupiter's largest
moon taking high-resolution digital
photographs
for years howard stayed a revolting
sex-obsessed creep
who hit on any woman he saw never mind
he never actually attracted a woman to
his sleazy bedroom
in the house he shared with his
overbearing mother
however the howard at the end of the big
bang theory is a different man entirely
by then he's been happily married for
years to burn a debt
and he does his best to make her happy
the only other female on his radar
is his toddler daughter hallie he's also
established a successful career
as a scientist and engineer the dude
even went to space with nasa
how's that for a big bang ending while
the big bang theory
is a sitcom about a group of scientists
who are best friends
it's really the story of one man sheldon
cooper
they can't function without me i'm the
social glue that holds this little group
together
never before had a sitcom as broad and
mainstream as this
attempted to include a main character
who is one of the smartest people in the
world
that's because sitcom characters are
generally both relatable
and amiable and sheldon is well neither
of those things
after graduating from college as a
teenager he went on to study the secrets
of the universe as a theoretical
physicist
he may be proven a smartypants but for
most of the big bang's run
sheldon's social skills were about as
charming as a moon rock
sheldon i'm not ready to have a baby oh
yes you are
i track your cycle over the 12 seasons
however
sheldon cooper learns how to be a
conscientious person
even if at a snail's pace and in the
two-part series finale
sheldon wins a nobel prize the ultimate
recognition for a high-end researcher of
his caliber
and a crowning achievement in a career
full of scientific breakthroughs
the episode's climax is an emotional one
when sheldon uses part of his speech to
express
at long last profound gratitude for his
friends
and wife and co-nobel laureate amy
i wouldn't be up here if it weren't for
some very important people in my life
check out one of our newest videos right
here
plus even more looper videos about your
favorite stuff are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one